serious charges against the st. Louis
couple who say they were just defending
themselves when they displayed their
weapons as protesters marched past their
home last month it happened shortly
after the George Floyd killing in
Minneapolis ignited that firestorm of
racial unrest throughout the country you
remember these pictures these images
we've seen the couple now they're being
charged chief breaking news
correspondent race Gallagher has the
breaking details tonight could even
trace Brett good evening mark and
Patricia McCluskey who on June 5th
confronted those st. Louis protesters
have now been charged with unlawful use
of a weapon the couple both of whom were
lawyers have not been arrested but will
soon be given a notice to appear in
court st. Louis Circuit attorney
Kimberly M Gardner wrote in part quoting
here today my office filed charges
against mark and Patricia McCluskey
following an incident involving peaceful
unarmed protesters On June 28th it is
illegal to waive weapons in a
threatening manner at those
participating in nonviolent protest and
while we are fortunate this situation
did not escalate into deadly force this
type of conduct is unacceptable in st.
Louis Gardner said she decided on
charges after a thorough investigation
by the st. Louis Police but police also
reportedly found the weapons were not
loaded and that mrs. McCluskey's gun
wasn't even real an attorney for the
couple said the charges are quote
disheartening as I unequivocally believe
no crime was committed and missouri
governor mike parsons had said that if
charges against the couple were filed he
was prepared to exercise his pardon
powers the governor went on to say even
without a pardon the couple would likely
not be doing any jail time and the
prosecutor today appeared to back that
up claim she says that that she believes
the best course of action here is for
the McCluskey's to participate in a
diversion program which is kind of
designed to keep them out of the court
system so far we have not heard directly
from the McCluskey's themselves right
Trish Gallagher
thank you